así que empezando un nuevo examen examen
número 6 sección número 3 del ojo así
que vamos a darle estamos en el primer
problema y siempre que empezamos una
sección yo estoy muy emocionado espero
que vengan problemas bastante
interesantes y recuerda que el examen de
7 es un examen contra tiempo por lo
tanto vamos a intentar resolverlos en el
menor tiempo posible y el problema
número uno me dicen cuál los siguientes
incisos es un número antes de mi resto
cuando los siguientes incisos es un
número que está entre un quinto entre un
quinto y un cuarto o que yo quiero un
número le voy a poner x un número que
esté entre estos dos que sean más grande
que un quinto y más chico que un cuarto
y sí es cierto que un quinto es más
chico que un cuarto pues vamos a ver de
hecho todos los inicios que me dan me
los dan en decimal me diciendo sobre 10
3 sobre 10 etcétera por lo tanto a qué
te parece si
y transformamos esto su parte decimal un
quinto un quinto nosotros sabemos que es
de aquí es lo mismo que 0.20 puntos
tiene que ser menor que x que tiene que
ser menor que y cuánto es un cuarto un
cuarto también está muy fácil esto es lo
mismo que 0.25 por lo tanto es cierto un
cuarto es más grande que un quinto y si
nosotros nos fijamos en nuestros incisos
el único que cumple que está en 3.2 y
punto 25 es el inciso d por lo tanto mi
respuesta es el inciso d y como supe
cómo llegué a la conclusión de que un
quinto es 0.2 bueno pues la imagen lo
único que hizo fue dividir 1 entre 5 y
aquí no me cabe ninguna vez entonces
pongo un cero por un punto y justo
cuando pongo el punto bajo aquí un cero
y dice 5 cabe dos veces en 10 2 veces 10
2 por 5 10 y entonces no me sobran nada
aquí se va a hacer
lo único que hice fue una división con
punto este mal así que bueno este
ejercicio estaba muy fácil es como para
calentar motores así que vamos a hacer
el ejercicio número dos los siguientes
puntos están en el plano cartesiano x
ok qué punto está más cercano el origen
y me dan los incisos am
déjame poniente aquí los puntos y los
valores de los incisos el inciso am me
dice el punto cero coma menos uno ok el
inciso b me dice el punto cero coma un
medio
ok el inciso se me dice que estamos en
el punto un medio coma menos un medio ok
aquí el inciso de me dice que es el
valor el punto perdón un medio como un
medio estos dos tienen la misma
distancia a b c d y el inciso me dice el
menos 1 - 1 - 1 coma menos 1 ok qué te
parece
si hacemos aquí una pequeña gráfica para
ver en dónde están nuestros puntos
vamos a hacer nuestros ejes por aquí y
tengo por aquí a mí es que yo lo voy a
hacer más o menos por acá
este va a ser mi hija y lo que por aquí
tengo también eje x porque aquí tengo mi
eje x ok algo así vamos a ver si aquí me
caben esta es mi hija y este es mi eje x
y vamos a hacer una escala muy pequeña
solamente tengo puntos entre 1 y 0 2
basta acá va a ser uno ok por acá a la
mitad va a ser un medio ok por acá de la
misma distancia por acá va a ser 1 vamos
bien por acá a la mitad va a ser un
medio ok por acá por acá va a ser menos
1 y por acá va a ser menos un medio y de
igual manera para acá por acá tengo el
menos uno y por acá la mitad tengo el
miedo es un medio así que vamos a
posicionar estos puntos y recuerda que
no estamos fijando en el origen estamos
comparando la distancia de estos puntos
con el origen
el primer punto es este de aquí 0,21 0,1
estamos hasta acá por lo tanto la
distancia en la que me voy a fijar es
esta distancia de aquí esta distancia de
aquí es muy primer candidato bien vamos
a fijarnos en el segundo punto 0,1 medio
cero coma con medio es este punto de
aquí y si te das cuenta esta distancia
este de aquí es mucho más corta que esta
distancia de kim de hecho ya insual
podemos cancelar porque porque esta
distancia es más grande de hecho es el
doble de grande que la distancia que hay
de un medio a cero no nos movimos en el
eje de las x nos mantenemos en el mismo
valor en x y aquí tengo una distancia de
una unidad de 0 a menos 1 hay una unidad
y aquí tengo una distancia de media
unidad por lo tanto esta distancia es la
más corta
ok vamos a ver qué pasa con el inciso c
el inciso 6 voy a cambiar el color
salmón un medio coma menos un medio un
medio coma menos un medio estamos
posicionados justo
es decir me voy a fijar en esta
distancia de aquí hasta acá cual será
más pequeña será esta distancia más
pequeña que esta distancia de clima y
bueno en este dibujo se ve claramente
que no de hecho esta distancia se ve que
es más grande que esta distancia y eso
es cierto podemos tomar de hecho un
teorema de pitágoras esta distancia de
que acá déjame ponerla con otro color
la distancia de aquí acá es un medio la
distancia de que acá es un medio y
entonces como me quedaría el valor de
esta distancia bueno pues esta distancia
de salmond quienes es la raíz cuadrada
me voy a poner aquí la raíz cuadrada de
un medio al cuadrado más un metro
cuadrado de un medio al cuadrado todo
eso al cuadrado más un medio todo esto
al cuadrado y cuantos esto bueno pues
esto es la raíz cuadrada de un cuarto
más un cuarto que es un medio es la raíz
cuadrada de un medio y quiere más grande
un medio con la raíz cuadrada de un
medio recuerda que cualquier número
entre cero y uno su raíz cuadrada
es más grande que ese mismo número es
decir a esta distancia es un medio y un
medio es más pequeño que la raíz
cuadrada de un medio y es más lo puedes
comprobar elevando ambas partes de esta
desigualdad al cuadrado entonces esta
distancia es mucho más grande que esta
distancia por lo tanto vamos a quitar
esta de kim y sigue siendo mi candidato
predilecto el inciso b vamos a ver qué
es lo que me pasa con el inciso d no voy
a poner con otro color con otro color
esté aquí el inciso d es un medio un
medio un medio un medio estamos justo
aquí y pasa lo mismo te das cuenta me
tengo que fijar en esta distancia y esta
distancia es exactamente la misma que
esta distancia y por lo tanto habíamos
concluido justo ahorita que es más larga
esta distancia que esta distancia de
rojo por lo tanto este tampoco me
funciona y este este ya se fue hasta al
menos uno como menos uno lo podemos
descartar luego luego menos uno con al
menos uno está por aquí y fíjate la
distancia tremenda que hay de aquí hasta
acá es una distancia muy grande de hecho
en la distancia
es de 2 y raíz de dos es mucho más
grande que un medio mucho más grande que
uno por lo tanto mi ganador de este
problema número dos es el inciso b el
punto cero coma un medio pero como un
medio esta distancia de aquí está de
rojo fue mi distancia más pequeña que
hay entre todos estos puntos hasta
llegar al origen esta distancia de aquí
muy bien aunque el problema número dos
estuvo entretenido borramos la pantalla
volvemos la pantalla y vamos a hacer
ahora el problema número 13 y en este
problema tenemos a una figura parecida a
ésta así que déjame hacerla tengo algo
más o menos como paul y ok
y después tengo a una recta que cruza
como por aquí algo más veloz y ok
después tengo a otra recta que cruza más
o menos como por aquí algo más o menos
así más o menos así más o menos algo así
ok
después por acá tengo otros dos y otras
dos rectas pequeñas metros de rectas ok
abel tengo una figura más o menos así
más o menos porque si me queda un poco
raro así que imagínate que esté en este
punto convergen todos y me dicen que
este este ángulo vale x este vale x este
vale x este vale x este vale x este vale
x este vale x y éste para desentonar
vale ya y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale
ok y no como función de x lo que me
preguntan es el valor exacto de 10 habrá
forma de conseguirlo
creo que la respuesta es que si si se
sigue fíjate en todos estos ángulos de
aquí hasta acá este es el tipo este es
la clave de este problema fijarse en
todos estos ángulos de aquí hasta acá
cuantas veces tengo x bueno si te das
cuenta tengo 1 2 3 4 5 veces x de aquí
hasta acá es decir que 5 veces x esto
tiene que ser igual a cuántos y te das
cuenta todos estos ángulos este este
este este y este forman un ángulo de 180
grados por lo tanto estos cinco ángulos
estas cinco x son ángulos suplementarios
eso quiere decir que 5 x tiene que ser
igual a 180 grados a 180 grados todos
estos de aquí y de aquí ya tengo una
ecuación en la cual podrá obtener el
valor de x xi 5x vale 180 grados
entonces x va a valer 180 entre 5
y esto es lo mismo que
33 y bajó a 36 grados 36 grados aquí lo
podemos hacer 180 entre 5 vamos a ver si
me equivoqué en estos 33 por 5 es 15 15
menos me sobran 3 bajos de 0 y digo 5
cabe seis veces en 36 veces en 30 y aquí
ya me residuos 0 36 grados vale cada uno
de los ángulos de x ok y eso le sirve
claro que sí
ahora fíjate en esta otra parte de
nuestro dibujo en nuestra parte superior
de nuestro dibujo en esta parte superior
es otro dibujo date cuenta que también
estamos formando un ángulo de 180 grados
es decir que james x mas x son ángulos
suplementarios y lo voy a escribir aquí
porque eso es muy importante
mas x mas x 10 más xx me tiene que dar
180 grados es decir la parte de arriba
de esta recta ok y si ya sabemos el
valor de x x vale 36 grados
cuanto vale bien pues ya más 36 36 es 72
72 es igual a 180 grados y de aquí y
aquí puedo despejar allí y es lo mismo
que 180 grados menos 72 grados grados
grados ok y cuando néstor pues ya es
igual a 108 grados a 108 grados y date
cuenta que tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque si aquí tengo que cinco
veces cinco veces x es 180 grados que
vale 3 veces x esto lo podría dividir
aquí ya que en por los valores de x
aquí
borrando vamos a borrar déjame borrar
tantito desde aquí yo te lo ponemos esto
puede ser un valor de x esto también
podría ser otro valor de x a este de
aquí y esto también de aquí por lo tanto
tiene que valer tres veces x esto lo que
vale hay en el ángulo de aquí hasta acá
y cuántos tres veces x pues vamos a ver
si llegamos a lo mismo a 108 36 por 33
por 618 llevamos una tres por tres son
nueve y una siendo una que llevábamos
108 que es justo lo que yo quería
llevarle 108 grados ya lo vimos de dos
maneras distintas una despejando
hablando de agudos suplementarios y la
otra dándonos cuenta que james es 3
veces x ya está la respuesta de este
problema número 3 así que vamos al
siguiente problema borrando pantalla y
el problema número 4 o el problema
número 4 y por el tiempo creo que va a
ser mi último problema de éste
de este vídeo dice 65-65 si 6.565 esto
es igual a 65 x x + 1 x x + 1 cuanto
vale x
cuanto vale x
creo que este problema no está tan
difícil qué te parece si divido ambas
partes de esta ecuación entre 65 entre
este 65 de aquí lo voy a dividir entre
65 de tal manera que estos dos se van a
cancelar creo que es lo que tienes que
hacer en este problema se me hace que
estos son los problemas rapidísimos de
resolver los cuales tienen una solución
muy rápida y cuánto es 65 65 dividido
entre 65 cuánto es 6.565 entre 65 bueno
pues cabe una vez 1.65 65 los restos
sobran 0 bajo el 6
ojo no bajo el 65 recuerda que vamos
bajando uno a uno aquí esta es la trampa
de este problema justo aquí te puedes
equivocar
bajo solamente el 6 y digo cuántas veces
cabe 65 en 6 pues ninguna vez entonces
pongo 100 por 60 y 50 para 66 y ahora sí
bajo el 5 y pongo aquí este 5 y digo
cuántas veces cabe 65 65 pues cabe una
vez
165 85 m residuo es cero
ten cuidado te puedes equivocar diciendo
que 6.500 65 entre 65 es 11 veces y en
ese momento ya te salió mal el problema
ten cuidado si lo hacemos con cuidado
nos vamos a dar cuenta que cabe 101
veces eso que quiere decir que voy a
obtener la ecuación la división de estos
dos es 101 101 es igual estos dos se
fueron a x + 1 y de aquí ya puedo
obtener el valor de x de una manera muy
rápida cuanto vale x
bueno pues de aquí puede obtener que x
es igual a siempre si yo paso este uno
de otro lado con signo contrario si lo
restó uno de ambos lados de esta
ecuación obtengo que x vale 100 es la
respuesta de este problema número 4 que
por cierto es el inciso c así que me he
quedado sin tiempo por aquí voy a dejar
este vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente
donde resolveré más problemas de este
examen número 6 sección número 3 hasta
el siguiente vídeo